what would you have done differently oh
I would have done that I would have
moved into the hardware business faster
and recognized that what we had in the
PC where there was a separation of chips
systems and software wasn't largely
going to reproduce itself uh in the
mobile world I wish I'd thought about
the model of subsidizing phones through
the operators we were still suffering
what I would call some of the effects of
our Vista release of Windows which
sucked up a huge amount of resource for
a much longer period of time than it
should have because we stumbled over it
I certainly wanted to buy Nokia the
board at first disagreed with that and
then came back and said the company
should should go ahead even though I had
decided to to leave